hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
sub-targets simple genotyping fast and
easy protocols to determine smn1 and SMS
to copy number and apoE allele
identification presented by Ryan
Donnelly product manager Canon
biomedical
I am Kaylee baka blabbers and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by Lavery's and
sponsored by canon biomedical for more
information about our sponsors visit WWN
FIO medical comm before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during this presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the street well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask question box and
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming Ryan
Donnelly I will now turn the
presentation over to him thanks for that
introduction Kaylee we're excited to
bring to you today some really quick and
simple protocols person traditionally
difficult to analyze targets
specifically copy number changes related
to the smn1 and smn2 gene as well as how
you can go about investigating common
snips in the apoE gene some quick
disclaimers before we get into the meat
of the presentation the products that
you're going to see here related to the
novalee align as products encanta
biomedical are all for research use only
not for you some diagnostic procedures
if you need to find out any licensing
information or product specific
information you can find those in our
user guides for the specific product so
we're going to list here online at canna
biomedical wwk n /
medical calm or for my kind of
representative we as can biomedical
support the products directly in the US
if you're in the UK or Ireland we have a
distributor through lab tech Canada is
through Cedar Lane the Benelux region is
supported through Sam bio and the doc
region which includes Switzerland
Austria and Germany is supported through
BIOS all and the last thing to touch on
here is Nova Lille as a trademark of
Cana biomedical so now that we got that
other way we can start the actual
presentation from an attendant
perspective we wanted to outline Canon
and genetics a little a little bit of
background on Canon biomechanical then
get into selecting genotyping
technologies for difficult to analyze
targets so what separate considerations
go into choosing a method for these
investigations and then the next two
sections will be related to applications
that we support through the Nova legal
product line so the first one is we will
look through our copy number solution
for smn1 and to copy number
determination we'll look at the method
and some data analysis for those and
then similarly we will run through the
method and data analysis for snip
genotyping example in this presentation
we're going to use the apoE gene to to
show that example
rounding out the end of the presentation
we have a analysis software that we'll
walk through that the novalee HRM
analyzer software we can show you how to
use that and lastly how would you go
about finding more information about
these products if you so desire so these
seem like a solution that you want to
try out in your lab how do you go about
finding finding these products on the
candid sight
you
things first Canada in genetics you may
be wondering why we're here maybe
wondering if we have cameras or
microscopes for your life science
research we get that question a lot and
the answer is actually no so we're
taking a step
adjacent to some of the more imaging
focused technologies that Canon is
well-known for worldwide canon
biomedical focuses on genotyping
chemistry's so chemistry's for snip
insertion deletion testing as well as
copy number identification and that's
where canon biomedical is focused Kenna
biomedical was launched in 2015 it's a
subsidiary of candide USA the desire
here was really to go beyond the
adjacent company's subsidiaries a Canon
has that do some work in digital imaging
and digital x-ray and push further into
the biomedical field so that's where
cannibal medical was launched out of so
as I mentioned we launched in 2015
toward the end of 2015 we launched the
first products for Canon biomedical
these were genotyping assays and
reagents specifically for snip mutations
insertions deletions we have some
mitochondrial DNA targets as well
the primary focus area for these is in
neuroscience research and
pharmacogenetics this product line will
be the example that we touch on when we
look into the apoE mutations from from
the protocol example we expanded beyond
that in November 2016 listening to
customers one of their desires was to
have characterized controls for the
assays so we ended up launching control
sets for each of the genotyping assays
in November of 2016 so for all but a few
of the genotyping targets that we have
we have a matched control set for those
which is really important when you get
into more rare mutations and lastly late
last year
October in 2017 we rolled out copy
number assays so we had heard from the
market and you're looking for a simple
and quick method to investigate copy
number changes in smn1 and to the
technique that we use we'll get into a
little bit later high resolution melting
allows us to kind of bring in this
application you know it goes well beyond
the simple snip and in dull detection
that we had initially launched with it
allowed us to open up this new
application
you
so the next thing we wanted to touch on
just kind of go over background on the
methods available if you're not doing
investigations in your lab so what type
of genotyping technologies are out there
and we give a little bit of an overview
around the Nova Leal method so there's
many different types of research so
we've broken it down into a few
different areas so from a pre screening
perspective what we mean here is kind of
inclusion or exclusion criteria for
sequencing studies so the thought here
is instead of sending all samples for
sequencing if you can pick up common
mutations that exist within them you
don't you likely if the sequence fewer
of your samples the next into a true
screening perspective when we say
screening our thought here is really we
see a lot of interest around CRISPR
clone generations so using genotyping in
lieu of Sanger sequencing to pick out
the clones that have picked up either
the knockout or the insert from your
CRISPR studies and lastly verification
so we see a lot of discovery work kind
of basic research around snip arrays so
the thought there is if you pick up a
handful of snips on the snip array and
use a targeted genotyping approach as a
parallel method to make sure that that
snippet actually exists on the city
within a sample and across all these
different types of research they're
different mutations that can exist so
we've talked a little bit about snips
insertions and deletions copy number
variations can exist there are arrays
that pick up a global copy number
changes methylation signatures can
change and also you know somatic
mutations which are thorough genius
through samples are also things that can
pop up
so when you're looking at options you
know lockdown the application that
you're going after then the technology
options start start bubbling up to the
surface and we can try to pick which one
makes the most sense so there's many
different methods out there
next-generation sequencing which is
really kind of one of the ultimate
discovery tools to Sanger sequencing
which is a gold standard for mutation
detection hydrolysis probe PCR there are
multiple millions of snip assays around
these these hydrolysis probe based PC
are great for targeted approach or
single Plex assays and then
high-resolution melting analysis which
the novalee align
based around and while it's a lesser
known technology there are many many
applications that are supported by this
technique so in essence it is an
endpoint PCR that is followed by melting
the product it's a very simple and quick
protocol but it has many applications
that go beyond what some of the like the
more targeted approach like hydrolysis
probe PCR can pick up
so once you have the the application and
the mutation type it really can drive
the method selection for your for your
genotyping studies test a little bit on
the basics of high resolution melting as
I had mentioned it is a standard
endpoint PCR followed by a melt at the
end to melt the product what we use is a
intercalating die so the die is not
attached to a probe unlike some of the
hydrolysis probe methods that we had
touched on so it's non target specific
it's an intercalated die sits in between
double-stranded DNA so at the end of the
PCR cycling it was the maximum
fluorescence because you have the most
double strand DNA available a melt
occurs at a fixed rate and throughout
the entirety of the melt fluorescence is
monitored so you're watching the decay
of fluorescence and it is this decay in
fluorescence which gives you a signature
in which you're able to pull out if
mutations are present if copy number
changes are present within the sample so
many features in
benefits of high-resolution melting
first thing I'll touch on is really kind
of what it looks like so in the top left
graph here you see three different
species of samples so the black curve is
the wild type so non-mutated the red
curve is a homozygous mutant sample so
both both alleles are mutated and what
you see here is just they both have a
similar shape it's one melt domain and
you just see a shift in the temperature
in which it melts and that makes sense
the wild type has two alleles that are
non mutated the homozygous mutant has
two alleles that are mutated so it's
within that sample is one one species
exists that's why you see a change in
the temperature in which they melt and
that's different from the heterozygous
mutation where you have one allele that
is non mutated and one allele that is
mutated so now when you have two species
that exists so not only we see a
temperature shift they all CC you also
see two different melt domains and
that's why you in this example you see
kind of two different melt transitions
there in the in the blue curve from a
benefits perspective it's quite a the
methods quite accurate Alden oval
genotyping and copy number assays or
thorough the bench tested for consistent
results it's quite cost-effective as I
mentioned did they to fluoresce and die
it's not a fluorescent probe so it's
from a chemistry perspective it's quite
cost effective it's very fast it's a
standard PCR followed by ml results in
you know a few minutes after your PCR is
completed it's very simple so really
only requires a high-resolution melting
compatible and enabled thermal cycler
and as I alluded to in the previous
slide about applications it's very
versatile so we can pick up snips
insertions deletions very large
deletions which are interesting and copy
number changes and those are specific to
what Nova Leal covers but going beyond
that high resolution melting can be used
to investigate methylation signatures
mutation scanning
and even triplet repeats
so I kind of touched on this already
kind of the targets the target types
that novalee supports snips that we'll
touch on for the AoE the fov mutations
copy number variations this will be the
SML one to example mitochondrial DNA we
have targets available for that small
and moderate insertions and deletions
which are pretty common for genotyping
investigations so these can there are
other parallel methods like hydrolysis
probes that can pick these up but for
large insertions and deletions those you
know those don't show up in the menus
for those hydrolysis probe PCRs so with
novalee we actually have athletes that
pick up up to a 7 point 6 kb deletion in
the hexa gene so this allows us to
really cast the net wide when we're
talking about insertions and deletions
and what size of those we can pick up
with with the technology specifically
for neuville it's a very fast and simple
protocol we would it requires extracted
DNA to be mixed with the specific assay
of interest along with the noble master
mix so upstream of plating the DNA is
extracted within a really commercial
available DNA extraction kit the
reactions are mixed up with template DNA
the assay of interest and then the
master mix those are plated and dropped
on to a HRM compatible thermo cycler
where the PCR melt take place and then
the results can be either analyzed on
the native software available to the
thermal cycler or they can be analyzed
using the Novo HRM analyzer software
which we will go into into more detail
towards the end of the presentation
so when I mentioned that you'll need an
HRM compatible thermocycler to do the
genotyping or copy number investigations
with the novo to the line you might be
asking well what are those
you know what companies offer those
there are many that available that are
available a lot of the real time PCR
instrumentation have this capability so
we do a bulk of our development work on
the bio-rad CFX system
in-house we've done cross-platform
testing on Roche system so the very
slight psychological edge stick or two
at the LC 480 kaijin has a system that
we have that we do testing on the rotor
jin-kyu thermo Fisher with a quant
studio has a melting module that you can
add bio fire has an older system the LS
32 and Cole Palmer eco 48 so we've seen
similar data across all these systems we
have all these ones listed in-house
we've done a lot of testing on them so
yeah similar data across them and having
the ability that many instruments you
know have this high resolution melting
application going to built-in you might
actually have one of these in your lab
or down the hall one of your partner one
of your colleagues labs
you
so that'll be from a general overview of
the Nova wheel line what we wanted to
really spend a bulk of the time on for
the webinar was around the two
applications
the first being copy number variation
analysis of the smn1 and two genes so
that's where we're going to start and
when we talk about copy number variation
I run into this a lot at trade shows
talking to individuals or just targeted
potential sites
[Music]
copy number variation can mean different
things to different individuals so a lot
of groups think of it as kind of
genome-wide copy number changes it's
very different than what we're trying to
do here so our copy number variation
assays our gene specific we have them
for smn1 and smn2 and so what we look at
is deletions and duplications of that
gene so a normal sample would have two
copies of smn1 the deletions we can pick
up are either heterozygous deletion so
one copy of SM and one still exists or
homozygous deletion so zero copies of
estimate won't exist in the sample on
the flip side of that duplications so we
can pick up if there's a duplication
that's one one in the sample and the
example here that we show is there's
actually three copies of the smn1 gene
so we
sites for both smn1 to the thought
behind that is there's a lot of homology
on between the two genes and the biology
is quite interesting between the two of
them so from a homology perspective
there is really one base pair difference
between the two genes they both create
SMN protein but due to the one base pair
change in SM into a bulk of the protein
end up being truncated and is therefore
non-functional so a majority of the
functional estimate SMN protein comes
from the smn1 gene so when looking to
design an assay around these two genes
understanding the homology that exists
it really required us to go about this
and make sure that we had extreme
specificity between the two assays in
order to not pick up a nonspecific
amplification of the adjacent gene
there are some other kited methods
commercial methods available to
researchers who are looking at
investigating copy number changes in SM
and 1 & 2 those are really digital PCR
droplet digital PCR and ml ta they're
available from a workflow perspective
the Canon method depending on your
instrument of choice can be done in
around an hour the quants video
specifically returns results in under an
hour so that would be the PCR protocol
plus the mail protocol is done with in
under an hour so it's very fast so the
other methods I mentioned here droplet
digital PCR on MLP a definitely both
have advantages well drop a digital PCR
is great for if your research question
has you trying to go about answering if
there's higher copy numbers that exist
in differentiating between the two so
maybe you want to understand samples
have you know five versus six copies of
specimen two that would be a great
method to go about that in MLP a while
it can take a long time it's highly
multiplex so you can pick up some
related snips as well that show up in
specific groups related to these genes
but if you're looking for a very simple
and fast method for determining 0 1 2 or
3 or more copies of SMM 1 & 2 no bhalil
is a great solution for you that being
said that i think the next logical
question was how does it work so there's
a few things to call out here the first
is we're looking at relative
fluorescence
and we've set this up we've set
reactions up to be competitive we set
them up to be competitive in two ways we
limited dntps available in the assay mix
and we also limit the cycle number so we
actually reduce the cycle number down to
25 in order to keep reactions out of the
plateau phase if we were to allow
reactions to get into the plateau phase
we would lose all of the relative
fluorescence differences between samples
of varying copy number another thing to
call out is the assays are set up in a
duplex
so for each assay will have a target
amplification so either estimate one or
smn2 as well as a reference gene so in
this case the housekeeping gene of known
2 copies one of the things that we do a
little bit differently though is you'll
see the reference there in the graph on
the left the rightmost not melt them in
you'll see some variability in the
fluorescence of the reference and I'll
get to why that exists second so
first you will see a fluorescence
difference in the target amplification
so in the leftmost graph the left most
melt domain you will see four different
kind of clusters there so a black
cluster which is pretty much flat line a
blue cluster a red cluster which is
above the blue and then a green cluster
which is seen above the red cluster so
those are separated out by the more
copies of the target that exists the
higher the fluorescence there now what's
interesting is because we've set these
up to be competitive again from the
target versus the reference that's why
you actually see the spread in the
reference genes fluorescence so the
higher number of primer binding sites in
either the target or the reference
allows for more amplification of that of
that region so the example I'll give
here is since there are no copies of
smn1 in the black curve you see kind of
flatlined under the target amplification
and the reference amplification for that
sample cluster you get the highest
amount of fluorescent therapy there's no
competition for the reference gene
inversely the green sample set you see
has the highest fluorescence from target
and the least fluorescence in the
reference gene because the target has
more primer binding sites than what we
see in the reference so in this case we
have three copies of estimate one in the
green cluster and due to the fact that
the reference is a housekeeping gene is
known to copies it only has two copies
available for amplification for the
reference gene so we can use this
inverse relationship to our advantage in
that you can really use both
fluorescence signatures both the target
and the reference to separate out
samples a different copy number
so in the rightmost graph it's the same
data as the left ground
it's just shown in a different way so
this is a difference plot so you're able
to select a one of the clusters selected
as a baseline in this case we the blue
curve which is one copy freshman one we
zero that down and then you'll see there
you're actually seeing the two different
melt domain so the leftmost domain is
the SMN one targeted the rightmost
domain is the reference and both of
those pieces of data exist to separate
out the samples based on copy number and
what you'll see what would you do see in
the rightmost graph the way actually
make the call is a panel of controls
that run you have the option of starting
with Coryell controls for zero one two
three copies of that specific gene you
run those on the plate with your unknown
samples and then the call is made by
seeing which one of the controls each
one of your samples has clustered with
so you are on the panel of controls and
then based on the clustering pattern in
the difference plot of the remaining
samples you can assign copy number calls
to each of the samples so the question
there is you know which one of these in
my sample cluster within a cluster with
the zero copy control that means the
sample zero copies that it closer with
the two copy control if it's two copies
as I had mentioned when we're looking at
the protocol differences investigating
higher copy number changes and picking
up the differences between say five
versus six copies of a gene is more
difficult the fluorescence change
between the two is much smaller than say
two versus one copies of a gene for that
it's the reality should have around 50%
fluorescence since one copy versus two
copies when you start getting into five
versus six six versus seven the delta
fluorescence between those samples
shrinks so we are confident for both of
these assays to call out zero one two
and three or more copies above three
copies it gets difficult to to
reproducibly call examples of those
higher copy number calls so we're
confident clustering everything that you
know three or more we are very confident
in making that call you'll see an
example in the s/m and to graph on the
right that we actually ran a five copy
control there you can just see how close
that starts getting if you go out a four
copy control in there as well which we
don't have it would be split between the
three and five copy curve sets and you
can just see how quickly kind of the
fluorescence differences between samples
breaks down so we're happy with these
claims and we've done a lot of testing
internally to make sure that they are
very reproducible across sample types
and sorry extraction methods and an
instrumentation
that brings us to the end of the copy
number application and we want to
transition into a more standard
genotyping application in this example
we'll look at some snipped genotyping
assets for this we're going to look at
the apoE gene so a Polly long form of
the name April lipoprotein e lipoprotein
so traditionally biology Y is associated
with many things in the cardiovascular
system so that is an existence but also
over the large it shows up in a lot of
Alzheimer's disease research as well and
that may be where it's even more
well-known for the two most common snips
Naoe gene are shown here so we have the
c-- dot 388 t to see this relates to
assisting to arginine change at residue
130 within the gene you'll see another
counting there where it might be one
hundred and twelve amino acid residue
but that's the legacy name so we'll
focus on we want that are bolded here
any other snip that will show the 526 C
2 T and this equates to an arginine to
sustain a change at residue 176
from a data perspective it looks quite
different than the copy number data that
we just looked at from a protocol
perspective though it is very similar so
it's just a simple PCR followed by a
melt the cycle numbers are higher than
what we see in copy number because we
can actually we allow these reactions to
plateau out to the genotyping since
we're not looking at relative
fluorescence changes but we wanted to
show some sample data sets for this so
what you're seeing here this is the C
dot 388 T to see assay you'll see three
different species shown here so the wild
type is the black curve set at a lower
temperature melt the blue is the
homozygous mutant shown at a higher TM
and as I had mentioned before when
you're looking at genotyping changes the
wild type in the homozygous mutant I
will be differentiated but at the
temperatures at which they melt they
show a very similar fluorescence
signature so one main melt just
separated by the temperature in which
they melt at and then you'll see a bunch
of pet mutants here in red and the way
those show up you'll likely see a melt
domain one under the wild type and one
under the homozygous mutant melts and at
a lower fluorescence because you're in
reality of one version of each of those
alleles present in the sample one thing
that is very important with
high-resolution melting is your wild
type
will not always be at a lower
temperature on it can swap places with
the homozygous mutant so while it's
important to differentiate the two you
can't always assume that one of those
would be you can't always assume that
the wild-type would be able to lower TM
like it's shown here we have asses where
it's swapped with the homozygous mutant
exists at a lower temperature than the
wild-type so in that case you know
controls are really necessary so we had
heard from you know our customers after
we launched the assays now having
characterized controls for all these
assays would be a really nice thing to
offer so we went about putting a product
together that answers that answers that
need so for each of the assays - a
couple of the assays we have available
we have around 300 genotyping assays
available we have characterized mutation
so are characterized control sets and
what you get with each of these control
sets is a homozygous wild-type and a
homozygous mutant control that you can
run on your plate with your samples of
interest the nice thing is they're
diluted down ready to use at a stock
concentration at the same stock
concentration we have for the samples
that get loaded on your plate so you can
use them right next to it in the same
pretty much the same type of setup
and here's what those look like so the
wildtype control shown in black you'll
see clusters very closely with unknown
sample - so the call there would be a
wild type / unknown sample - on the
other side of that you'll see the home
control is the blue curve and the green
curve unknown sample one tracks very
closely to that home control to get a
hat call there is the ability to mix
these together we have a blog article
about how to do this coming out very
soon so check back to the cannon
biomedical blog in lieu of that do you
have confidence in making the college is
based off the dual melt peaks of a head
so long as they exist under those the
melt demands that you would expect from
the homozygous mutant and the wild-type
you can go that route also
so as I touched on we have over 300
different genotyping assays around 80 of
which are related to neuroscience so we
have some in the GBA gene not the first
gene that a lot of people think of
related to neuroscience but there's been
some research showing showing up in
Parkinson's disease as well as the hexa
gene which we see in relation to pay
sacks so many different many different
targets for both of those genes for
hexes specifically we had touched on
that very large deletion assay that as
far as we know there's no targeted
method to resolve that deletion outside
of the novalee line
you
so we've seen a lot of data figures
between the copy number variation
application and the genotyping snip
application in the data that you've seen
has been generated using the Novo HRM
analyzer software so we want to show you
a little bit about how that works so we
had put together a very intuitive
easy-to-use interface for individuals
either currently running high resolution
melthing assays or that would look like
to bring them into their lab using high
resolution melting and this is kind of a
screenshot of the layout it's very
powerful there's many different ways
that you can go about normalizing data
and analyzing data so we have some curve
normalization that helps with
normalization of fluorescence there's a
negative derivative plot you see this in
the bottom left and that's used for
genotyping to making your genotyping
calls related to snips and in Dells and
the we do curve comparisons in the via
clustering that's in the bottom right
graph and that is more similar to what
you saw in the copy number application
so clustering the controls to the
samples so this supports both the
genotyping and copy number applications
with one with one software two
access it the website is seen here it's
free to use its cloud-based it requires
a science of first name last name email
address very simple to use if you're
currently running high resolution
melting assays in your lab you this is
supported by a number of the more common
high resolution melting capable
instruments with for seamless data
upload for ones that aren't supported we
can help with kind of formatting an
excel table to get the data in here so
it can be analyzed if you already have
high resolution melting data and you're
just looking for a maybe a more elegant
or simple to use or user-friendly
analysis software feel free to check out
the Novo HRM analyzer software or if
you're looking specifically for the nova
little assays we highly recommend you go
about using this our support team is
very happy with it and the customers
that have used it I really liked it
really brings us to the close of our
webinar here so we have just wanted to
relay there's interest in the specific
applications or even the targets that we
touched on today so copy number changes
in SML one and two or snips in a buoy
and show you how to go about finding
those or as we spoke about we have many
many more genotyping assays available
and how to go about searching for those
so ANOVA little assays in chemistry the
copy number assays are packaged for 200
reactions in each vial these are 10
microliters reactions student typing
packages a little bit smaller 166 and
the controls meshed and genotyping
assays we package diluted down ready to
use 30 reactions per vial we have
different kind of app
focus areas here so a bulk of the
genotyping assays fall into either
neurology ient or pharmacogenetics
research so we have a very large menu of
cyp related mutations as well even
you'll see here the things that we
haven't talked about so things like
inherited disease related targets
metabolism related targets and
cardiovascular genotyping assays are
also where we have a lot of coverage
across those research areas a couple
different ways to find an assay so you
can go in browse this is what's shown on
the left
so we've what's called discover zones so
things like I mentioned cardiovascular
inherited is the metabolism neuroscience
pharmacogenetics if your research takes
you or focus around one of these areas
feel free to browse assays that are
related to those research areas or if
you have a gene of interest or mutation
of interest you can feel free to search
use the search function that's shown on
the right you can search by gene name
RSI D clinvar nomenclature or omen
nomenclature to name a few and that can
take you to your assay of interest even
quicker
and lastly how to go about you know if
you if the applications are in line with
your research needs and we have the
target of interest for you how do you go
about contacting us so in the beginning
of the presentation we kind of called
this out but in the u.s. we sell direct
through Canon biomedical so phone number
email address is shown here so contact
us at Canon - biomechanical comm or one
844 Canon bio for a phone number and
then if you're outside of us we have a
large growing distributor network so if
you see your country here the
distributor is listed next to it and
their website if your country is not
listed we are continuing to grow our
distributor network so feel free to
reach out to us at the contact us email
address and we'll be happy to get back
in touch with you look I have an update
of new countries that we bring online
so I have spoken for way too long and we
wanted to open it up make sure we had
enough time for questions from the
audience
so with that let's open it up and see if
there's any questions
Thank You Ryan for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many questions now we
have penciler all right let's get
started
our first question is you showed correos
control so you used in the copy number
analysis can I use my own Bank sample
that have already been characterized as
controls instead
that's a very good question absolutely
so we had when we were doing the
development of the assays we wanted to
make sure they worked with a third-party
control so if a lab didn't have bank
samples away with characterized copy
number changes that they could you know
still bring in the bring in the assay
and use some readily available cordial
controls so that's why we had started
there but absolutely if you have
characterized samples tucked away or
have accessed through a colleague of
yours feel free to use them as your
controls for for the copy number a so it
will work absolutely fine
great and we have one time for one more
question and this one feeds off of that
it says do you offer this as a service
we actually get this question a lot at
trade shows and we're at a customer
sites we don't offer this is a service
so the thought here was to put together
a genotyping method that researchers who
want to kind of bring this into their
own lab or have it done more quickly
than they send out service that they
would have access to do so so
unfortunately with the data that you saw
with the target that we're going after
for the applications that we've touched
on we don't do that testing in-house but
we are happy to help bring your lab you
bring it to where it needs and help out
from a experimental setup perspective
and we can help out with the data
analysis to bring these types of
applications into your own lab
wonderful I would like to once again
thank Ryan for his presentation I would
also like to thank cannon biomechanical
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2018 you will receive an
email from labyrinth letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon
goodbye